المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
ان المنظمه الدوليه ستناقش مع اعضاء مجلس
الامن امكانيه فتح المزيد من المعابر
الحدوديه لادخال المساعدات الانسانيه الى
سوريا واضافته على سؤال للجزيره ان هدف
الامم المتحده انسانيه وانها لا تسعى الى
تاسيس قضيه حساسه للغايه
الامين العام كان واضحا جدا عندما قال ان
فتح المزيد من نقاط العبور سيكون افضل
اعتقد اننا سنبدا المناقشات مع اعضاء مجلس
الامن وسنجري بعض المشاورات لمعرفه ما اذا
كان بامكاننا التحرك في هذا الاتجاه لكنني
ارى انه من المهم التاكيد على ان هدفنا هو
تقديم المزيد من المساعدات الانسانيه لا
تسيس قضيه مسيسه بالفعل وحساسه للغايه لذا
فان هدفنا انساني وسنعمل مع اعضاء المجلس
وبالطبع سنعمل مع الحكومه السوريه لتحقيق
ذلك